hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to I love
whores I love everything about them how
willing they are to sell their souls for
money and how cheerful they can be in
the process oh I'm not talking about the
people that sell their body no no I'm
talking about media Morris the people
will create stories and ideas solely for
the purpose of selling their product and
in the late 80s early 90s there's no
better brothel for media whores than
Nintendo now before you go nuts
I love Nintendo who does it's like the
greatest gaming company in the world but
that doesn't mean they didn't sell out
time after time when it came to their
spin-off products mostly in television
and movie development time after time
Nintendo has put out horribly written
and horribly executed shows and films
that have no interest in actually
entertaining the viewer but rather just
selling more Nintendo games and
accessories and here's another one
captain in the game master is captain
and the game master the Saturday morning
TV show that instantly made you want to
play more Nintendo games why because
anything was better than watching this
piss-poor children I'll really take shit
so get out your Nintendo blasters and
game pads we're gonna take a look at
captain it so let's take a look at the
story of this show it seems everything
takes place in the fictional realm
called
video land welcome to video land
yes I imagine you'd have to be in order
to watch this it turns out the palace of
power is under attack by evil forces
carrying a evil pizza cutters I would
insert that oh do sound effect here but
I don't need to they already put it in I
do love it when the show makes the jokes
for me so the evil forces are led by
King Hippo from the game punch-out
eggplant wizard from kid icarus and
mother ring from Metroid's it won't be
long before ah beautiful goddess but I
am God it's like if my yuccas became a
drank by the way tell me a best sassy
voice sounds familiar
I'll be the beautiful queen of video
land just look at anima 2 you pump
that's right it's the plan from Little
Shop of Horrors
I guess he's just always playing
generally ambiguous monsters with no
feet
why do you animate could never be me so
this is what would happen if you cross
Joan Rivers with Tina Turner that's
right meanwhile inside the palace of
power we see the other videogame
characters trying to protect the palace
like Mega Man a pleasure to serve you
your worship you get a low score for
this and Kid Icarus trusts you I trust
you it's like a cough I smoked an entire
Marlboro Factory Kid Icarus would later
be known in the gaming world as pit
she's very much of Senecas my arrows
would stop that it because Maximus
speaking over hide-a-goose yeah you
probably caught on that his funny thing
is saying it gives at the end of words
in fucking genius there's someone in
your Dorcas you can count on me too it's
a circus you like to kill to the drug to
kiss and son and Bella from the
Castlevania games mega man shine my
boots Kid Icarus I could use a little
trim not too much off the top oh Simon
what are they done to you
I know they took this cool badass of a
superhero and turn him into a poppy
egotistical
gaywad I am the handsomest so I must
find the princess and kiss her it's like
if Bruce Campbell's chin never stop
growing yeah
scram I mean where did they even get the
idea to get him up so much I mean the
original hero has long hair wears
leather carries a whip jumps around in
the skirt I think it just answered my
own question but a real man Julia how
it's done the ruler of the palace of
power is princess Lana oh yeah from the
game a DS fashion vomit okay so Lana was
never actually a video game character
they just made her up you may have
helped me win the battle but the war is
far from over and like a lot of these
shows I gotta ask again why the hell
isn't she a queen I mean I know younger
girls associate princesses with youth
and beauty but come on if there's no one
else there to rule you're a goddamn
queen it is I we should apologize to you
but just like a lot of our shows I've
reviewed they get to keep their cute
little title because the king is still
technically alive but just not around
I've tried to lead our people since you
disappeared but I failed you I'm still a
princess because my mother's stuck yeah
that's it
in a parallel dimension oh that witch
where he has no royal authority so I
don't have to make any hard choices or
take any responsibility because he's
still technically his King and I just
have to swallow and wear pretty dresses
politics is fun so seeing how there's
only four people and no guards in the
palace I guess we're not surprised that
it's being taken over but luckily a
magical element informs our heroes that
a lone warrior is being summoned to help
them magical elements simply known as
the power glove The Legend of video Land
4 tells of a young warrior he is Captain
end the game master behold the ultimate
so it's like the power glove of the
freakin God where the hell that gets at
to magical entity I love to power glove
it's so good
look darling so the power glove goes
into the real world or at least what we
consider the real world in the 80s as a
young gamer named Kevin gets sucked into
the realms on video lab by the way do
you know what the fuck this is
it's only on the screen for a second but
they always showed it in the opening I
can never tell if that's something
sucking him in or that is him being
sucked in is that what happens when you
cross that bitches you become the CG
version of Kermit the Frog of Max
Headroom it's not easy being Duncan
Duncan green so Kevin and his little dog
too are transported to the palace of
power where mana and the others are
waiting Simon Belmont
Kid Icarus may go mad Wow
you look nothing like your original
designs the ultimate warp zone brought
you here you mean like warp zone 4 and
Super Mario Brothers no backing is much
cooler the legend foretold of your
coming to help restore freedom to our
world that's why it gave you that
superpower pad and zapper only 1995
available on most video game outlets
Castlevania Kid Icarus Mega Man or
whatever the hell this chick was in on
also okay this is the plot to captain n
our five heroes trying to stop the evil
mother brain from taking over the palace
of power captain in the game master by
the way I know this is really immature
but have you ever listened to the
announcer say that title without
actually reading it it sounds different
listen captain
the gamemaster doesn't sound like that I
mean I know I just made a gay joke but
that's what it sounds like when the more
appropriate title be captain n the
sexually confused you physically an
emotionally open minded master so you
know aside from lame lines nonsensical
stories and completely misunderstood
character development what specifically
is wrong with this show well how about
the fact that nothing in this world is
consistent for example we clearly see
that pretty much any time he wants Kevin
can use his Nintendo pad to pause
reality well why the hell doesn't he
just do that all the time
would that make everything a lot easier
I mean how come he never confront mother
brain like this prepare to meet your
match captain II I'm awesome
captain in the game master or how about
these warp zones that they keep using we
can apparently jump from world to world
whatever they want so why don't they
just work to the inside of the enemies
room and Zampa if I may do that a few
times it seems so easy except they don't
bring any guards or armies they just use
the eggplant guy who shits out some
vegetables I'm just an incompetent
vegetable again why doesn't Kevin just
use the warp zone to shoot mother brain
when she's in the middle of a hammy
speech I'm awesome
captain in the game master but no
there's always some lame-ass excuse as
to why he can't just blaster into the
warp zones it's too dang
we're contractually obligated to keep
stalling for three more seasons there's
also things that were never in the games
that they just flat-out made up like did
you know that sign that Belmont Swift
literally has a mind of its own
I am NOT going to anything but my quip
is going to work you now his sexual
preference I can't speak for ya it's
pretty easy to make fun of this guy
especially when you see how he's
defeated half the time a bag the
greatest vampire hunter in the world is
defeated by a bag this guy couldn't
defeat Count Chocula of course also it's
the Kevin's mother worried about it I
mean there's gotta be missing posters
all throughout the neighborhood would
she be worried sick in fact in the first
episode he actually has a chance to go
back but decides not to that's a good
lesson for the kids right if it comes
down to video games or your family
always pick the fucking video games
better not be playing that foolish game
you have all work to do and don't forget
to take out the trash on second thought
I guess I could stay just a little while
longer hmm life-threatening situations a
certain doom or taking out the trash and
fun filing those police reports mom that
and the animation is just horrible and I
mean horrible like look at the
expression on Simon's face here did he
just give himself a full frontal
lobotomy no uninjured cast iron spire
I got accept credit card jewels and look
at this they actually forgot to put in
the background are you fucking serious
and trust me this isn't like any kind of
artistic license here they're in the
middle of the bayou
there is no reason it should look like
this and I understand if they did it
maybe once by accident but I counted it
they do it seven times seven that's
right seven yes that seven I guess they
could have oh I don't know
watch this before they send it out to
air I mean I do know it requires
actually sitting through an entire
episode and Bloor knows they're hard
enough to watch but my thought is that
would sort of be required I mean
seriously
one more I would just have a plain white
background the whole entire time he'd be
a fucking idiot and how about these
rocking dance moves that the heroes have
Wow if you thought white people dancing
was bad
try animated white people dancing that's
right princess move that one leg pull
out the geriatric drowning look
as the show sadly got more and more
popular they actually decided to add a
new character just blatantly called Game
Boy that you'd never guess what product
they're trying to push here idiot you're
coming
apparently Lana's father who's trapped
in the dimension of cheap cop-out
writing has decided that instead of him
entering back into the real world he'll
send this marketing ploy I've decided it
is best for video land to send another
with my please he is called game boy
anyone who doesn't have one will be
loser run out to the video stores now
the double-talk come on shoot pictures
till they get game boy who really has no
personality or characteristics except
for the fact that sounds like a crappy
download of slime yes game boy will be
all gorgeous hero as he ruins all your
possessions try shooting you an armed
combat machinery and even manages to
destroy your kitchen appliances sorry I
am a good King but probably the episode
that most people remember is the Zelda
episode where captain n literally does a
crossover with Lincoln Zelda from the
Super Mario Brothers Super Show how does
this come about
little Zelda gets in contact with the
palace of power for assistance hyrule
calling the palace of power we are need
of a hero I would use the one we have
now but will excuse yeah that's not
gonna work
so Kevin works his way down to Hyrule
because they heard rumors that Ganon is
not yet destroyed and they actually be
regaining his power
you're a real video Legend where I come
from like that's why your name never
appears in the title so the knows how to
pay for top billing but it's weird
because it's the same voice actors but
not exactly the same design I mean link
looks like he got stuck in a fucking
potato sack when did the character look
like that Zelda promptly doesn't look
any better wah boy
Zella go I'll need you to heroes can Pat
yourselves on the back some other time
I guess she's taking the Disney princess
approach and god bless her for it
we have important business oh yeah right
cannon
I thought you wiped enough were good so
did I but we just heard a rumor that
someone's trying to bring him back
they're searching for a magic potion
that will restore his power we've got to
find it first
well yes I remember that magic element
that was meant to bring back an evil
that was almost destroyed in fact I was
there I was there with the strength of
men now
cast it into the fire
this triad
no suck of my big fat meaty bars
Mario Marc should've ended that day
there is no strength left anyway Kevin
Ling Zelda and Gameboy all travel to the
village to see if they can find any info
on the potion of power excuse me
don't be afraid I like hope the peasants
actually dressed more royally than zelda
that's a pretty bad sign
thank you for saving my phone kind sir
please take this as a reward it's a map
to an ancient desert palace that will
unlock the potion of power you seek all
those peasants carry maps to potions of
power
it's like backward hats you've just
caught on so if they continue on their
quest they find that link isn't exactly
a fan of kena as they constantly try to
show off in front of each other in case
you haven't noticed this isn't a game I
just can't stand your life Yeah right
I'll get it you're the hotshot game
master monocots bigger than your cock my
packs double the size that yours is but
can you really blame him for getting
upset Zelda kisses Kevin in like a
millisecond hasn't link been trying to
get her to do that for years we did it
respect Hyrule thanks to you fucking
cock tease we'll save your ass over and
over just not enough to get a little
visit to first base fuck you
so they fight through all sorts of
baddies until they finally get to the
potion of power guarded by a knight
named metalhead
he's not soda no kidding Zelda can't
chew that's what really happens but a
Planet hippo get the potion as they give
it to Ganon to help him regain his
strength friends for my coming-out party
you know I had suspicions about the
dress but uh really this is sort of a
surprise
my pork sausage is your pork sausage so
the master of evil now has all this
power how are they going to stop in
so again is a bit of a push who do the
best team of Heroes ever let's celebrate
by pretending to make a pizza
so that's captain then the game master
what a loaded dump it's just like
playing a real video game - the presence
of actually enjoying it if I thought
worse this was a video game that way I
could just use my game genie to jump all
the way to the end credits whose name's
Gwen so deadly all happen to be Alan
Smithee
me personally I can't wait for half my
cast of the show to turn up on video
game confessions wait you want to get
that it it involves mother brains
genitalia alright alright God don't you
understand okay remember it so you don't
have to captain in the game master